let's bring you some breaking news it's  just hitting us via the Reuters news  wire regarding the scandal surrounding  Dominic Cummings very well reported on  Kate birdies breakfast show just a few  minutes ago we're hearing that the the  junior minister the Scotland Douglas  Ross has resigned in his position over  behavior of Dominic Cummings that's come  from a tweet that's just hit in the last  few minutes I think we've got the tweet  now so I can read it for you he goes on  to say I haven't commented publicly on  the situation for Dominic Cummings as I  have waited to hear the full details I  welcome the statement to clarify matters  but there remains aspects of the  explanation which I have trouble with as  a result I have resigned as a government  minister so that is the latest news that  Douglas Ross jr. Minister for Scotland  has resigned after the scandal  surrounding Dominic coming